vous n'ignorez pas que ces garçons
viennent de tous les horizons de sont
généralement de milieux modestes et elle
qui aujourd'hui porte et porte la tenue
hier était encore charpentiers
menuisiers cultivateurs marins pompiers
si vous dire que ces garçons font sont
pétris et de la même origine que nous
qu'ils ont leurs problèmes personnels
professionnels et sachez que cet égard
ils ne sont pas minces bas un phénomène
assez curieux mais qui est tout de même
facilement explicable généralement on
attache beaucoup plus d'importance et on
remarque davantage leurs actions à
maintien de l'ordre plutôt que leur
action quotidienne
pourtant il faut bien reconnaître que
c'est bien là l'aspect le plus positif
de l'activité des gardiens de la paix en
effet vous avez le problème de la
circulation ils ont aussi une autre
activité qui est celle de la protection
des écoliers ceux de la police secours
un bon nombre de sauvetages également et
il est bien évident que grâce à leur
action
un grand nombre de vies humaines a pu
être sauvée
bien fait débat qu'il faut faire un
joueur c'est à dire qu'il ya d'une part
les crs vous n'êtes pas les crs on est
bien d'accord mais ce qu'il ya de
regrettable c'est que des fois on vous
fait on vous fait faire des actions qui
sont assimilables au rôle des crs et crs
on n'a pas en discuter ici c'est pas
c'est pas vous bon faut pas vous
comprendre non plus le malaise c'est que
provient essentiellement de l'activité
en maintien de l'ordre également aussi
il faut le dire
cela tient au fait on met pas c'est
souvent un relief tout l'aspect positif
de leur profession par contre ces
garçons se trouve en matière de l'ordre
un face d'une poignée de fauteurs de
troubles et qui au fond emploi arguments
l'injure la provocation la calomnie et
pour moyens d'action la violence est ce
qu'on de partenaires de temps en temps
me le reprocher de leur part aussi une
certaine violence
je ne pense pas qu'on puisse reprocher
au gardien une action énergique pour
rester maîtres de la rue pour faire
respecter l'ordre public car dans
certaines circonstances et n'y a pas si
longtemps ils se sont trouvées exposées
pendant des heures aux injures aux
calomnies et aux provocations toutes
sortes sans qu'il y ait une réaction ne
leur pas assez vite
mais rien j'amène des flammes vous avez
un bâtiment qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est un problème qui est encore bien
construit je pense par georges hamel jc
là
puisqu'elle empêche la violence une
bonne idée d'ailleurs été écoutées
lorsqu'elles faisant pêche de tenir la
proposition dite à tout moment y fait ce
temps de venir manifester avec un
bouquet de fleurs et moi j'aime et moi
je vous assure que les gardes d'appel
sentiront palma très bien lorsque vous
avez un manifestant blessé
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien
simplement la sphère est monté en
épingle
pendant le même temps vous avez bon
nombre de gardiens qui sont parfois dans
un état plus grave qui sont hospitalisés
dans l'indifférence générale
le seul moyen c'est cesser de gueuler
dans la rue main pour vous écoute jamais
autrement qu'à ses tout comme la langue
basque
mais vous savez la manifestation quelque
chose constitutionnel bien souvent on
oublie on parle toujours de répression
de manifestations mais ce sont toujours
les désordres qui sont réprimé une
manifestation c'est quelque chose de
normal le traditionnel et les gardiens
de la paix en tant que citoyen en tant
que syndic et en tant que fonctionnaire
je pense aux lois également de
manifester sur tout cela forme pacifisme
ils l'ont été aujourd'hui de raison du
oui
oui ils ont raison parce qu'il y en a
c'est qu'il met qui les méprise sa ison
de sa vk départ ils sont méprisés
il faut de l'ordre nous les autres et
ouvriers parce que nous puisse
comprendre
et est ce que n'ont pas de problèmes
aussi est ce que si nous n'avions pas la
police et quelque fois que deux
faisons pas intéressant mais généralités
que ce soit pour le service de la route
et où je sais que moi et me soumet
plusieurs fois tiens quand il s'agit de
poser un problème qui est important il
ya il n'y a pas plusieurs moyens enfin
il ya qu un seul moyen qui se rendre
efficace et de de le poser en groupe est
le poser face à la population je pense
que actuellement les agents sont en
train de reconnaître que c'est un moyen
très important je ne me prononce pas en
tout cas tant que je vois discutait
aimablement avec les gauchistes je dit
mon dieu il vaut mieux que les varices
clinique des machines à cette
manifestation
c'est limité à paris est ce à dire qu'en
province il n'y a pas de malaise qui
guardian après de la police mais le
malaise est exactement le même en
province il n'est pas exclut d'ailleurs
que dans tes jours ou l'ordi semaine
prochaine il y ait des mouvements
similaires
engagé sur toutes les grandes villes et
dans tous les commissariats de la
province il faut bien que le public
comprenne que ce sont précisément ces
gardiens qui ne pensent qu'à se dévouer
pour le bien public que ses gardiens
s'il n'était pas là et bien très
rapidement s'instaurer le désordre et
l'insécurité
en attendant d'ailleurs que soit perdu
la paix et les libertés publiques
[Musique]